foreign
[Music]
s into the far reaches of space okay
imagine yourself 200 million light years
away at what is called the Perseus
Galaxy cluster oh wow can my friends
come with me yeah sure all right cool I
think we're together fool all right I'm
gonna bring my sword just in case
they're all together all right at the
center of it a super massive black hole
uh-huh
do you dare listen to its cursed sound
oh this is really spooky it's a sound
this is not super spooky NASA was able
to record the sound of a black hole oh
dude let's hear it I didn't know it made
sense my own it sounds like lift God
remember once you hear it
you can't unhear it if it carries any
kind of curse on your life that's on you
is it a wave file yeah let's listen to
it it's on YouTube by the way yeah is it
an mp3 for some demonic [ __ ] in my life
so let's go okay I thought it could even
I didn't even know you could make sound
I thought it was just the sound away but
because uh this Perseus Galaxy is filled
with so much gas it emits enough waves
for it to be translated into sound so
it's farting but it Cosmic fart the
sound itself is actually it's just a
comedian 57 octaves below middle C so
it's practically unhearable so it's like
but it's a different frequency yeah
through processing everything they've
made it here whoa yeah
Swizz Beatz into the NASA Studio Plus
ten
swizzy in the background ready guys you
imagine you're listening it's just DJ
okay here we go the curse of the Perseus
Galaxy is upon you
[Music]
it sounds like a thousand Souls
screaming oh cute that is a black hole
you're listening to that's so [ __ ]
cool man
can you should dance to this bangers
whoa
it just sounds like an airplane going
through the wind damn I think it sounds
crazy that's so cool though but that's
what I would imagine a [ __ ] black
hole it sounds really yeah that's what
you said close to it I mean something
similar it's either that or Enya
let's just imagine that's just Sandstorm
you just get today
oh
[Music]
I should be done with the name of it is
we all know it though huge in the 90s
yeah they played on KISS FM constantly
or the Scatman
[Laughter]
yeah that's 200 million light years away
that's so [ __ ] cool how did the thing
even get that far
out of that thing I elaborate I think
what's happening is it's reading waves
and taking those actual waves and
translating into what it would be audio
like it's like was it like a telescope
or something or is it like one of those
[ __ ] Rovers that went out there it's
nothing nothing's even out there they're
just observing it from Earth yeah it's
like it's like [ __ ] reading it's like
lip reading for the CIA through
binoculars it's an astronaut sound man
that's just floating
can you get me closer to the black hole
this day raid sucks ass bro because you
don't like that cam uh that camera they
had to send out there it's like that
they had to send it [ __ ] far so they
could get photos of like stars and [ __ ]
so I was like is this the same thing but
an audio recorder they said that
[ __ ] gigantic road yeah it's the
same thing from uh home alone it's a
talk boy
you got it
that's what the [ __ ] filthy animal
I saw this design for like um it's like
a it's like a telescope slash camera
right that's supposed to go far as [ __ ]
and then they're trying to figure out
ways of like how are we gonna make it go
like years and years and years obviously
it needs to generate its own like energy
like solar or whatever and then they
came up with this thing it's like a
sailboat so it's like oh catches like
Cosmic or like solar waves or whatever
yeah so it's like it's propelled by
solar technology but then also it
catches like the wind but you know
there's no wind but like that that force
and it just it just uses that as a way
to keep propelling it forward and then
with that it uses very little energy to
continue going like into other galaxies
and [ __ ] so I'm like damn and uh the
speed though is like
how are they gonna
do it within our lifetime you know oh
yeah it's gonna take like [ __ ] years
and to secure the funding yeah
right we're not gonna see a lot of the
coolest [ __ ] get made but it's in the
works but hopefully I won't see the end
of Earth so maybe there's that you don't
want to see that assuming we don't get
to the end of Earth for like a long time
in human existence I hope not dude this
the technology and like the space like
element is gonna be so gangster like in
in the later part of our we stopped
killing each other you know assuming
that's essential you know that whole
thing with uh colonizing Marsh and how
they're saying like oh the first people
like once it's once we're able to even
get there and there's like a safe
atmosphere whatever the first people to
go will never like see Earth again yeah
would you be down no [ __ ] no I like
Earth dude Earth is sick I don't even
want to go no Mars Mars could suck a
dick dude I don't give a [ __ ] about Mars
I don't even want to go to Lancaster I
don't want to go to [ __ ] mom
want to go out there that's like
pilgrims the pilgrims yeah exactly Never
See England again and they're like I'm
fine with that what if you have a
greater chance like let's say the
resources on Earth are just whole [ __ ]
everything's going bad you already know
the lifespan of humans on this planet
it's gonna be it's it's finite so what
if they said oh if you go to Mars and
you like help colonize your seed will at
least get a better chance at lasting
another few Generations unless you know
I don't care about no seeds man yeah
you can suck it too you know you have to
be a particular kind of like either
narcissist to be like I need to carry on
like my family name or you need to just
be like super like heroic and be like oh
yeah like this is for the greater good
of everyone okay or you got nothing to
attach yourself to you have no family in
general so just to complete loser
oh that's pretty cool too though and
you're just interested about Mars yeah
there has to be incentive what if it's
already been done let's say Mars is
colonized it's it's already arguably a
pretty cool place to go you just have
the option to go but you can't come back
I can't come back how all you know about
Mars is that people have been ready to
get five stars that's like Las Vegas
uh-huh yeah but who are the people
rating exactly are they other weirdos
other Jiu Jitsu singaporeans did you see
a good point I want to hang out with
those dudes if it's pretty cool yeah oh
yeah if it's like Singapore yeah zero
state income tax maybe but what if they
say that
as a scam because that's what they're
doing in America you know like in the
very beginning they're just like come to
the states we have gold on the [ __ ]
streets and everyone's like hell yeah
and then you get here and they're like
all right you're working that mine yep
you're building this railroad dude it's
like [ __ ] Interstellar like that one
dude that gets to the uh the one planet
and he was just like I lied I just
really wanted you could rescue
I was like oh that's really dark how
would I get it dude that was hella
realistic I love that [ __ ] though yeah
oh my God Mars sounds like MLM that's
what it sounds like wait what like
multi-level Mars like Mars Gooding I
feel like it's a pyramid scam yeah it's
a pyramid scheme yeah dude the
colonization of Mars was uh delegated to
Singapore only like hey Singapore you're
in charge of making Mars [ __ ] cool
then would you trust it low-key yeah I
would a little bit more but your boy's
still staying on Earth man
there has to be an inherent incentive
for me I got it Mars bought the rights
to [ __ ] Jujitsu and Hainan chicken
so here's the thing
it's but it's also uh unrealistic
uh expectation because it's not
practical at all yeah but I like
American attitude right because for us
it's like we're dope [ __ ] everyone else
right so that's that that's the used to
be so I need that spirit so it has to be
an American colony but I don't want it
to be American built I want it to be
built by Singapore because they do a
good job uh Singapore a merit link up
because that attitude is what creates
what created all the dopest [ __ ] of
America to be fair isn't the idea of
even colonizing Mars already the
American attitude yes coming from
whether it be NASA and or SpaceX that's
already American a lot of people
colonize but then right now the attitude
is like oh it's for the future if the
human race that's not [ __ ] Mountain
Dew enough yeah yeah [ __ ] mountains
do version I get what you mean do you
want do you want Mars to be sponsored do
you want to see like or do you want like
aliens on Mars so we have somebody to
genocide
if we get more genocide in Mars I'm in
no I'm joking I'm joking but not really
but yeah I really like gum so I don't
think I want single poor to [ __ ] with
Mars gum that's I was gonna say you
couldn't have gum on the entire [ __ ]
planets everywhere you have to import
let's say that Mars do Mars is cracking
okay but it doesn't concern you it's got
the Kraken yeah there's a foster program
like Dubai there's a foster program to
take in some aliens and uh in your
family or like a human that's been on
Mars that is now these [ __ ] has gills
they found when they got there would you
take one of those in how cool are they
is it cute like cute alien or is it like
you don't know you have no idea oh
what's a mystery but I want you to be
judgmental there's like Starship Trooper
alien you'll never know there's like
group you know that's what you say yeah
it's in a mystery box yeah
how big is the Box they come in like a
gotcha capsule like like the size like
the size of a of a medium-sized dog
medium-sized dog size dog not interested
wow do we know if there's diseases or no
Mars AIDS just or they're uh their
antibodies could cure your diseases
the only way okay is you get a rim job
by one of the aliens I knew it which
they call them
you want to meet more
eaters on Mars that just lick your
[ __ ] yeah dude if there was Amy nor
Mars who's gonna be the first one to try
it though God
I want to be healed he's Joe's mouth
I would move to Mars if they had the uh
cure to psoriasis yeah yeah that could
cure my psoriasis I'm in bro they have
medical saliva medical grade saliva what
would you do like let's say why are you
only asking me because you're the most
[ __ ] hateful
it's so hateful I'm not hateful bro I'm
very inclusive
hateful one you're the you're the least
to move out of Pasadena yeah no I'll
move out of passengers
he won't even move to a place that he
loves like Hawaii dude I'll move
practically anywhere anywhere there's a
[ __ ] Tenth Planet but a lot of it a
lot of things is like is determining on
one of my business and two your business
online dude dude I'm in person all
martians love Jiu Jitsu dude they'll
probably and your wife's a trump
supporter now you say yeah she is in
Lion Mars Jiu Jitsu dude well I'll come
home sometimes my wife is watching
Donald Trump compilation
just him roasting people she's like oh
my God babe did you see this and sort of
wind it five times over and over again
wow now she doesn't do that it's funny
to make jokes about that because she
gets really comfortable and it makes me
it makes me laugh all right and
especially when I say it's the internet
what if your wife said hey I really want
to go to Mars because it got new
Salvador
Salvador what are you gonna say then
I'll be like we staying here ladies what
if she's like I really want to go to
Mars your mom's out there I got mx-14
they got ms-14 out there what if they
got 14 is bigger number than 13. what if
they got new Pasadena there and it's the
same layout same everything but I'm
never going to [ __ ] there's unlimited
women's shoes everywhere wait what did
you say I love women's shoes all
Martians look like Hezbollah okay I'm in
dude he's so done
[Music]